[Music]
you
Thomas stole welcome to Stanford
University and system's leadership nice
to have you back thanks Rob great to be
here so tell us a little bit about Tonko
you started this new company what are
you up to well one of the things that
struck me at legendary in my last
company was using technology in that
case data analytics and data mining to
have a pretty profound impact on our
business principally what we started
with was you know advertising in a
different way deploying our capital in
different way and using data and
analytics to insert ourselves into this
decision-making process
so one of the things that occurred to me
is if you could use technology whether
it's data machine learning artificial
intelligence to go into businesses that
are not normally known for innovation
you could have a pretty material impact
so that's that's really the thesis of
telco is looking for companies in
traditionally large bit sleepy spaces
being able to use innovation and
technology to change the way they they
do businesses and hopefully do business
and hopefully get a get a material
impact how do you find these companies
and how do you know that they're right
for digital transformation well I mean
Minoo garden-variety way that we're
finding these companies we're getting
inbound phone calls you know we're
looking also at different sectors that
we think are interesting but as
important as anything is finding
managers finding management teams with
very deep domain expertise within these
industries that then you can back with
capital wherewithal and technology so
how do you find these companies adapt to
and bring in new technologies like
artificial intelligence and machine
learning to improve their businesses
what's that process like well as part of
that checklist you have to make sure
that the the management team embraces
using technology and in in cases where
we feel really good about the match it's
somebody that says look we're really
good at our business we know
we know our market inside now but if we
just had not only the right capital but
we know there's probably a smarter way
to do things but we just don't have that
expertise so when you can then empower
those management teams and and work with
them because we don't run the companies
they do that's where we're seeing pretty
great results well you have a team
behind you that's got a strong technical
background and technical expertise how
do you get comfortable knowing about the
company whether it's a good acquisition
target when you're not from that sector
well I think it's a number of things
we've developed sort of a checklist to
at least be a little bit of candle in
the wilderness for us now none of these
things are ever going to be perfect
right but but for us there's a number of
different attributes that make sense and
as you can imagine in most cases we're
we're not moving ahead right it's it's
it's not a venture fund where we're just
laying bets down we typically buy entire
companies or big stakes and companies so
we don't want to do so many that we
can't be effective but it's it's hard to
come up with sort of a one-size-fits-all
you sort of know when you see it you
want to make sure that it's checking all
the boxes that are important that you
you know you love the management team
you have shared philosophy on how you're
going to go forward and then at the end
of the day our big thing is can we cause
outcome right now be good Pickers but
cause outcome so you're moving your
family from Southern California back to
Pittsburgh where you're from originally
why'd you choose Pittsburgh as opposed
to the Bay Area or Boston or some other
part of the world well look I'm an East
Coast guy I bleed black and gold
obviously with the Steelers but one of
the things that has been unbelievable is
to watch the transformation that the
city of Pittsburgh has undergone really
pivoting from industry into biomed
incredible technology hub and Carnegie
Mellon University is is really right in
the center of that and it's doing some
incredible work around machine learning
at AI
so he went from laundromats to the movie
industry and now to factories in
automation and in industries in some of
them your work or as you said non-sexy
how did you come up with this idea to go
from what you were doing before with
legendary to this particular opportunity
well I think in my mind almost every
sector of our economy is going to be
touched in some way by AI robotics
technical innovation and you know the AI
and watching it both in terms of what we
did at legendary and then in some of the
personal investments I had made if you
can really force multiply you know it
got me really excited about it it's it's
challenging different problems every day
I get bored easily so you know being
able to have different problem sets to
try to tackle all the time was was
exciting to me as well so Thomas tell
you're on the tip of the arrow looking
from the financial and investment side
of the digital Industrial and
transformation we really appreciate your
coming to Stanford and telling us a
little bit about what you're up to
thanks Rob thanks so much
[Music]
you